[Music]
hey this is do you want rope with
Collider and we're here at the collider
studio at the kiya Telluride supper
suite in Park City first of all a huge
congrats on the movie to you guys I'm
here talking to everyone behind
possessor I want to jump right in and do
the generic question because everyone
watching this will have not seen the
movie yet so how have you been telling
your friends and family about the film
like what it's about just very very
vaguely and then carefully I've been
avoiding avoiding telling them anything
Oh for real yeah so you have you not
told like people like even a logline
there is a it's about someone who
controls another person using brain
implants and the intention is to get
them to commit an assassination one of
the things that I dig about movies like
this is when the technology involved is
something that's like you know on the
cusp of like maybe being able to happen
is that something that's always
fascinated you like what drew you to
that kind of storytelling yeah I mean I
think it's an interesting there's an
intersection between the science and the
philosophy of it because it's actually
rooted in old neuroscience from the 50s
and 60s they were experimenting with
brain implants back there back then and
they were able to control people's hands
and it was a bit more of a loose time
for for neuroscience and through brain
implants they could control emotions and
behavior of people so it is rooted in
that history but then philosophically
it's very interesting because it's a
question of if someone can move your
hand or if they can get you to fall in
love with someone by stimulating a part
of your brain who are you then and when
what is what is your will actually 100
absolutely for the two you describe I
guess I mean you must read a lot of
scripts what was it about this script
that really you felt compelling and you
were like I have to be in I want to be
in this well for me it it was actually
Brandon's first movie I loved his first
movie
and Anna and then read this script was
really excited about it mess him and I
think we like had a cup of tea and I was
like can I do this and you were like
yeah and then that was it that was
basically those who's really long
meeting wait I was sitting there how am
I gonna convince her to do the film and
then I asked him I was like do this you
know trying to be cool and everything
that was it I just think Brandon's
extraordinarily talented and the script
it's difficult because there's so little
that you I want to say in order to keep
it this fresh wonderful untouched
Odyssey that it is but the script was
beautiful
his first film I thought was so
innovative and interesting and that's
why sure yeah I mean I think it I think
it always starts kind of with the script
because before I met Brandon obviously I
read it first and what drew me to it was
there is an elegance I think in its
sparseness and they it's kind of a funny
line that you can be drawn sometimes
with sparseness and scripts because it
could be either a maturity or lack of
knowing what to write you know what I
mean but true I mean truthfully but
truly the latter in this case this one
this one no but this one this one I
think there's like a maturity to it and
and then for an actor it's like there's
room to kind of play you can like
between the lines and in that way
completely and also it was an original
idea which I really appreciate it it
wasn't it wasn't based on a book or
something like that which is fine but
you I feel like there's a lot is a lot
of scripts in our adaptation of
something or other and the fact that it
was completely original idea I was very
impressed by and then I met Brandon and
you know we really clicked and I
couldn't wait to do it wait a little
while but I couldn't wait to do it and
part of the innovation was talking to
him about how he's cinematically going
to achieve everything because there are
a lot of things that were cooked up
basically in a very
more room between you and Kareem are
incredible DP that hadn't been cooked up
before they were they were trying out so
much we didn't know what it was gonna
look like we didn't know how it was
gonna work and I haven't seen the film
and I'm watching for the first time
tonight because I wanted to see it in
its entirety and with good sound and I
know that I presume it's gonna be a
cinematic feast so which is why we're
doing this interview before you see it
so that when the crushing disappointment
yeah crashing ly disappointed I have to
ask this is this is not a this is well
there-there's a little blood in this
movie do you think they're actually me
rephrase it there's a little there's a
lot of blood talk a little bit about
like that balance of you know violence
and what you're willing to put on screen
and do or I mean yeah yeah absolutely
um I think well two things I think in
general in a way there's something to me
that's less disturbing about explicit
violence in films because the violence
plays as horrifying in a way that
violence is horrifying I find it more
unsettling if you have really sanitized
violence and you know someone shoots 200
people over the course of the film they
never bleed it's a pg-13 action movie to
me that's that's actually weirder and
more unsettling than a film that depicts
violence in a really visceral way but
also for this film in particular the
violence is very narrative I mean the
way it's depicted has a lot to do with
the character psychology without without
giving too much away there are different
approaches to it in different scenes and
it has a lot to do with the characters
experience and relationship with
violence by the way I strongly strongly
agree with your statement about pg-13
movies and how much violence can be
depicted with it's insane to me you said
you can kill 200 people and it's pg-13
it's crazy
every movie no matter there's always
limitations of money and time talk a
little bit about the what you were
nervous to be able to pull off in the
time and
money that you had and maybe if you guys
felt any of that I mean it's as it's a
science fiction world but it's kind of
an alternate universe science fiction
world that feels very familiar I think
any time you're doing that there's some
there's some game that you're playing
where you you want it to feel different
you want it to not just feel like you
didn't have the money to do a huge
future world so going into it not sort
of I guess finding that balance where
it's a different it's a different world
it's science fiction but it doesn't feel
cheap was it was something I don't know
but it kind of it ended up not being too
much of a struggle in that way I think a
lot of the effects we were doing were
practical which ended up being I would
say better and but also cheaper and it
was never really conceived of as a
massive sci-fi film with hover cars or
anything so I mean I I think it's I kind
of like a certain amount a healthy
amount of limitations I think when it
comes to that I think if maybe if you
have too much time or too much money
sometimes you can you can kind of go
overboard with ideas and decisions but
when you're limited I kind of I think it
kind of forces you at least I'll speak
from an actor perspective or my own
perspective that I enjoy I enjoy a time
the time limitation sometimes sometimes
would be nicer to do more takes if you
have time and but we never actually had
that issue on this film I never nothing
ever felt rushed but I do think certain
amount of limitations that come with
time or budget I I think can be good it
was it was actually a pleasure because
you you know we walk onto certain I feel
like the beginning of every one of
Brandon's directorial sentences was this
is gonna seem really weird
and then something unique and very odd
had be achieved but they were so I mean
every that we had an amazing crew and
everybody was so prepared the production
design were excellent
the whip it you you we were so ready to
make this film by the time that we made
it and it was so mapped out in Brandon's
mind there was some times when I wanted
to be I think I said this to you I
wanted to be a dreadful movie with meg
Ryan and somebody who gets made small
and put in somebody's ear shouldn't say
dreadful it's wonderful
anyway wanted to be a small person and
be like downsizing thank you I actually
quite liked that movie to be honest if
I'm really honest and to be put inside
of his head just to know exactly what he
was looking for you know because
sometimes it was so specific but because
you were so clear about that I think it
was that we didn't need a lot of time
you know there must been a little bit
strange for you guys because I think the
on the one hand we have we spent a lot
of time developing it so we knew exactly
what we wanted to do on and on and on
the other hand also to work within those
limitations sometimes we'd be jumping
around a lot or we'd be getting very
specific stuff that was for a particular
effect or part of a scene or something
like that and so there was a little sort
of dance where we were trying to fit
everything in um I have a million
questions for you guys but I have to
stop and also because I don't want to do
any spoilers when we can talk more
freely about the movie and look forward
to continuing our conversation but for
now I just want to say sincerely
Congrats on the movie and I hope it's a
huge hit for you guys here at Sundance
thank you so much for coming by our
studio Thanks